[Music]
trowel prior last year with the Browns
had 79 catches a thousand yards four
touchdowns and turned down the Browns
offer to go to Washington for a one-year
deal to RL joins us now how's your
morale rel I'm doing well a long process
man and I just getting ready to get to
it you know it can't wait to work with
the new QB and other guys around and I'm
feeling pretty good have you talked to
Kirk Cousins yes i have several times
over via text message but he's a
Michigan State guy and you're an Ohio
State guy you got to get past that
awkward phase don't you the funny thing
is a right before chant last year he was
driving home from by IAT to go towards
Washington and I was going on my way to
Pittsburgh and we ran into each other at
a rest stop no we chatted there it was
crazy how things work there was no
tampering going on there you didn't talk
about maybe playing for the Redskins
with Kurt hey Dad been at that time I
had I had one catch I'll be one but you
got to the point and you did it right
trail you got to the point where you
said they're not gonna let me play
quarterback now how do I stay on the
football field but how difficult was
that to tell yourself you're not going
to be a quarterback in the NFL anymore I
mean you gotta think about it I mean
just from a life perspective um
everybody has you know their goals and
something they want to do in life [ __ ]
then after you're doing something for so
long and then you know and then you just
just realize you know what it's not
gonna work you know nobody's and give
you the right chance you're happy the
chances aren't there you know and then
you know it's kind of it's hard you know
but you also got to check your ego a lot
of you know there's a lot of you goes
flying around and I had to check myself
and say you know what
not working at QB you know I had a good
run good try at least I tried but you
know let's move on something else if I
keep me on the field and playing the
game that I love the dish so and that's
what the choice was were you the best
quarterback on the Browns last year it
is today again were you the best
quarterback on the Browns last year
Crockett no God Cody Kessler pretty good
Jessica yes I can't do that to my god
yeah but uh hey Doc I could play i would
i would have been ill play if we took
some bread are you the emergency
quarterback are you where are you on the
depth charge as far as quarterbacks go
with the redskins we never we never
spoke about that you know hopefully we
never ever ever had to get down to that
position i'd like to catch deep ass or
so from curt and uh make some explosive
the place or the receiver standpoint
maybe do a little trick play for one of
our touchdown or something like that
I'll be fun but we haven't spoke about
that did you face Josh Norman I last
year yes sir how did that go this
competitive man you got to check out the
voice nipa have zenna sent you to voice
nip of a hit me a jaw soft it was a
friendly a competitive battle hughes to
penis but offers a fiery batch i had a
loss how difficult though you put up
really good numbers in i don't know how
many quarterbacks you played for four
maybe but you know we hear about the
Browns dysfunction how tough was it in
that organization I don't want to really
shoot down you know the Browns I mean
they have a great organization you know
I just think that the piece there's some
pieces that were missing you know some
guys I'm off at the line obviously the
quarterback issues for such a long time
and I just think you know just the guys
they let go you know in terms of Taylor
gave you on a couple guys like Mac you
know they're just getting a bad name but
I think overall you know I really
respect the organization you know what
shop she's doing a coach Hugh Jackson
you know those guys a lot they gave me
an opportunity to playing on uh after
end of the day it's a business and I you
know I'm definitely looking forward to
playing for residents nice trail prior
and it's only a one year deal with
Washington right for now you know
everybody thinks it's not much speaking
for our Washington but you know and
that's something that we asked for
myself and my agents for one year deal
it's kind of like a movie deal almost to
a certain extent you know because I
think a lot of people are thinking that
this is a one trick pony tail like the
one one-time thing you know just I don't
know where I just couldn't catch 79
balls or whatever good and go over a
thousand yards so I got a lot of lot to
prove and I really can't wait i look
forward to it no i think people be
really naive if they didn't watch you
last year now granted you had to go out
of your way to sit through a Cleveland
Browns game trail just to be honest I
get paid to watch those games but
nobody's going to discount you get 79
catches last year with that team not at
all are you did you fill out a bracket I
did it no do you care you pick it oh I
can't tell you i'm in a bracket
challenge true you want you can be in
our bracket challenge if you want that's
not fair you're about to ask me about it
no I won you know if you were in the
bracket challenge and if you wanted to
be in the bracket challenge there's no
money that exchange his hands but you
could be in our bracket challenge and I
could see what you know about basketball
let's do it all right all right why not
do it when I put you on hold then we'll
we'll give you the link to our bracket
chances how good were you in basketball
in high school pretty good-looking
coming out on a lot of Scotland services
you nas Rick from anywhere from 30 and
below there's a couple out of 20 there's
one out of 15 and 1 hours about 39 I was
right out of the glove klay Thompson and
like two spots blowing behind there's a
few other guys are in the league still
to this day so I could play a little bit
did biggest school at off you dear
scholarship basketball lunch uh there's
a lot of schools i had about 110 offers
basketball when I didn't get I didn't
have Duke on there though oh you want
anything I will go there but well wait
if coach k calls and says trail I want
you to come in play basketball and
will will let you play a little football
if you want to but we want you to play
basketball would you go into Duke there
might a better chance actually because
Cutcliffe was there for football I mean
have had a great relationship peyton
manning's coach so yeah I don't know I
don't know I might have to come back go
back on those words you know I don't
know it would happen I don't know what
happened baby but you you could you can
have a long NBA career trail yeah but
but this there's something about the
physicality of football and just a sense
of uh yes go right now you know you have
to be there for a teammate you know yes
you have to work hard and that blood
sweat and tears through the offseason
get thrown to a game and knowing you're
you know you're about to get hit or you
have to be at your top of your game
every single day you know and I think
you have to do not i'm not all 11
players have to be on point you know to
win a football game you know LeBron
James we go out there and drop 60 70
points you know you shall twirl and sis
and they may they may win the game how
would the LeBron doing in nfm yes
freakish town you know I think if you if
he worked on some of his on some of the
craft I think he'd be it exploded on the
scene and being a phenomenal yeah I
think he's doing okay now but I just in
case you need to another career to fall
back on just you know he gets to be like
39 anyone's play tied in for the
Patriots you know you could see that
happening right never though brain you
would do it they only have a couple of
years left very hurry up i will put you
on hold and Frenchy will give you the
link to our bracket challenge we'll see
what you know about basketball but
congrats on the season in Cleveland and
good luck there in Washington thank you
sir that's a trail prior Washington
Redskins wide receiver the Dan Patrick
show weekday morning on audience